let's get a little optimistic i suppose
we have this story from the new york
times
well i should i'll say fairly optimistic
teen vogue editor resigns
after fury over racist tweets the hiring
of alexi mccammond who was supposed to
start the conde nast publication next
week
drew complaints because of racist and
homophobic tweets she had posted
a decade ago alexia mccammon is a black
woman
i believe i i don't the news calls her a
female you know person of color whatever
but
i believe she's black and uh
she got cancelled for being racist
against asians
which is a fracturing in the woke
theories the critical race theory
because asians are supposed to be the
ultra privileged it's like they they
they say
sats for instance asians have to score
higher than white people
that they have to score like a 1300 or
so compared to like a thousand or
whatever for a white person
well now you know we used to joke on the
show that i was double white for being
part asian so i'm like double privileged
now i don't know what i'm supposed to
think because apparently they're saying
that the hate crimes are against the
asian community
and this woman's getting fired for 10
year old tweets so so the reason i say
optimistic
they can't cancel every conservative
especially when some of these people are
independent
yeah when uh when you have people who
have their own youtube channels or work
for conservative outlets who will never
get fired
what do they do well they're like
they're like vampires you know
they have a bloodlust and they're
searching for someone to softest target
but you know the conservatives are
hardened have their shields up and are
defending their communities
so they're turning on themselves in
desperation exactly you go for the soft
target look
i get on twitter i say thing i get the
leftists attacking me
so what i don't care i don't care the
people who publish me don't care the
people who buy my books don't care
probably sells more books to be honest
uh maybe
and and by the way the uh battling
hierarchy
of oppressions was one of the topics in
in the books
the flag of the people's republic
america splits into two countries
flag of the people's republic keeps
changing they keep adding stripes
and it's like a running joke through it
except
it it it's except it's like real well
they they
you can't satirize these people well
they just report
have you seen so they there was the the
rainbow flag
yes then they added the black and brown
stripe for black and brown solidarity
and now they added the trans triangle to
it so it's just the flag is becoming
this is a triangle out right a rank a
stripe
i guess it's like i don't know i i mean
i don't i don't know who who's the most
depressed all a mirror mirror on the
wall
who's the most oppressed of us all you
know it's so s
the thing is even i fall into making the
mistake of calling it stupid
it is stupid but that's beside the point
it's insidious yeah i'm not going to be
able to talk
look you can't reason them out of it you
can't sit there and go
you know it's stupid to hold people's
immutable characteristics as defining
them
it's stupid it's also immoral and wrong
on every level you're religious
uh secular at every level it's it's
terrible
now believe what i do and they're like
no i get power from it screw you
yeah or you're not in the tribe so i
reject whatever it is you're saying
without evidence
uh it's just it it's ag but i think more
and more people
are coming around on it as a 30 years
ago we were talking about political
correct
politically correct stuff yeah i
remember
bill maher politically incorrect on abc
got fired for being flipped
in 1986 or seven
i was an editor of uh the uc san diego
california review which was a
conservative paper and we had a picture
of one of us sitting there going
here fred pete is drinking a glass of
politically incorrect
coors beer because the the coors guy
gave money to right wing thing
it was being used you know 35 years ago
and uh but it was kind of a niche thing
for conservatives conservatives whined
about it
i mean it's right to wine about but
they're still whining now
ever it's infecting normal people's
lives and they don't like it and you saw
with president trump he he got more
hispanic voters
oh yeah because like his male guys are
like i i i didn't sign up for this
yeah yeah i won for this garbage i
wonder if the
the the infighting people canceling
themselves i'll tell you this this woman
resigned right this alexie mccabe
resigned it's worse than that
uh we reported this before but a
seven-figure advertising deal was pulled
because the employees were complaining
about their new boss
so they the company effectively
cancelled itself
you understand like this is amazing
millions of dollars
i don't you know the the thing that
really got me was the new york times
with tom cotton
oh yeah where you had a senator writing
an article which i disagreed with by the
way i
actually wrote my law review article on
the use of military force in support of
civilian
civil support operations i'm largely
against it i think the military is
unsuited
in most cases when it's not emergency
here neither here they're there he
writes an article
that says we should use these guys we
should use military forces
to suppress some of the blm rioting
anti-variety
okay a position about half of americans
take he's a republican
they run this thing the news the the
woke kids at the new york times
go nuts and if i was the editor and they
marched into my office and said you
can't run this
i'd say okay you're at the new york
times
we run editorials from everybody if you
don't like it
get out if you do like it get out do
your job and the next one of you who
brings up this crap to me
is going to find himself walking the
streets get out
i got to say i can't do it i got to stop
you right there if it's me
and someone comes in and says that op-ed
you published
you need to get rid of it i would say
okay you're all fired everyone in the
office right now you've just lost your
job
i'll call security to ask you out of the
building or you're nicer than me because
i would give them a
learning opportunity i think i teach
them
not to be idiots but if they didn't do
it i would fire them
granted i wouldn't hire them in the
first place well that's that's also true
but let's let's
for the sake of the hypothetical the
thing is they rolled over
the guys in power rolled over why
all you gotta do is say no these guys
have a glass jaw hey
hey millennials screw you we're not
doing any of that
even if i hear about it again you can't
you know you could do
the person who's like you know speaking
you say you're fired
anyone else anyone else want to be fired
all right get out your work
you guys believe that look you guys
believe this is so important
let's see some principles i'm not going
to pound the table yeah how many are you
gonna quit
don't put put on the table and then
they'd come back and be like we need a
union to fight
against these things and uh that's
because they can't they can't negotiate
for themselves and stand up for their
own ideas have you noticed how the
uh new woke unions tend to not support
basic workers like old school union
ah we want to you know we want vacation
and we want health care
dental plan dental plan you know that
the old-school
teamster kind of stuff now it's all ah
we uh
we got this whole woke agenda we've got
it for us blah blah blah
unions unions aren't about no no
you see the united auto workers union oh
they're outraged
ford is going to be moving some of their
new car projects to mexico
and and it was really funny my favorite
line from ford was they were like well
things have changed since uh you know
circumstances changed
since our last contract negotiation and
do you know what that thing that changed
was
yes who was it it was the president
right who was it i said it right away
now it's that withered old zombie and
who is in hocked understand that the big
corporations
tend to be part of the liberal
establishment the democrat establishment
you know this whole i i saw they were uh
you know warren's
son we got to have a billionaire tax i'm
like
let's do it let's tax the billionaires
you think
why why again would i spend hey look i'm
a republican i'm not just a concern i am
a republican because i believe there's
got to be a party of the right and it's
the republicans for better
and mostly worse mostly worse but
why should we as republicans spend a
night oda
of our political capital defending the
uh financial influence interests of
people who
hate us and use their money to screw us
against our own financial interests
let them burn figure 20
20 cert tax on billionaires rock and
roll
yeah uh mackenzie bezos funds a ton of
critical race theory
george soros man conservatives don't
shut up about that guy so when i hear
that stuff i'm like who cares about
billionaires so i tweet out
you know like tax the rich and all these
i saw that all these lefties are like
based tim like tim's a lib and i'm like
dude i've always talked about
progressive taxes
tax the billionaires i don't care
there's like how many of them in this
country a handful
well look i oh well there's 300 if i
wanted to get back to my basic
conservative principles from when i used
to read a
national review on ironically um
and god help me weekly standard before
it became a
cheesy cruise brochure uh look i i would
say look i
i want a smaller government i want
people paying less taxes because that
star's government
that's a principle but i have another
conservative principle and it's a more
important one it's
i will i will accept no principle
that makes me less free and
unfortunately you get all these
conservatives
well you know it's a private company
can't do nothing that sounds like the
democrats right now
well it's like yeah and it's like well
yeah but i kind of don't like them
screwing with me and if you use your
power against me i'm going to use my
power against them
and uh if we're going to play the
principal's game i say they go first
this is about screwing me the weirdest
arguments you know i have with uh
objectivists or libertarians we we had a
river
so polluted it started on fire what was
it there was a coyote yeah
70s i think it was and then we had we
had a regulation to be like okay how
about
you can't dump that much pollution in
the water we got to regulate how much
you're doing
basically all these different companies
are saying don't look at me i only
dumped you know a tiny fraction it's
like yeah well when all of you dump at
the same time it makes a big mess and
bursts into flames
when our water is on fire we got
problems that's that would be an
indicator
so i've always i grew up with this stuff
i've always been in favor of regulating
companies that get out of control
and i also believe in some form of
regulation against government was out of
control the problem is the government
has a monopoly on force so how do you
deal with
a broken government that's tough however
i'm not going to ignore
when billionaires are exploiting the
system and taking advantage of the
working class
my my thing is i don't care if you're a
billionaire bro like
people talk about taxes and i made a
joke where i said i said tax the rich
right
and then a bunch of people were like
look at a mirror bro and then i quote
two to myself me and bernie will share
i said i said arrest the rich as a joke
and that was like me and bernie will
share a cell
i have um i have a jo i'm writing my
sixth book
and i'll give you a preview i have a
joke about there's a statue of bernie
sanders the late bernie sanders
because he he he passed away when he
dropped his bong
on some copies of socialist workers and
it caught the house on fire but the fire
department went to the wrong mansion
and it's a sad thought look no
no one does better under communism than
the cadre
yeah right i mean you know and uh there
are a lot of mensheviks running around
uh democrat washington a lot of these
guys
it's like your own people are gonna put
you against the wall figuratively
they openly say these people tweet these
things i know
they they they look when i when i hear
about bernie sanders bernie sanders
having multiple houses and millions of
dollars
i'm like i don't care what are his
principles
is he in favor of working class people
having rights or not well
arguably you can say yes to some
ideological split but it's fine okay i
think bernie sold out in a lot of ways
but then i look at soros the koch
brothers the mercers
jeff bezos mackenzie bezos tom steyer
michael bloomberg
why do these people get to shut down the
voices of the working class
but they're with their with their
massive wealth and not only that
but the the establishment that they
that they embody has been a disaster to
the american working class i wrote
another book a non-fiction called
militant normals about normal
people getting angry at what's happening
and i i
told the story of a guy who was a marine
he comes home
you know fictional and embellish it but
but basically you know he sees his job
sent
to another country and a guy who looks
like mitt romney drives up in a
limousine and
says well you know you guys you know you
can basically learn to code
some solar panels yeah build some solar
panels gotta go i i gotta be at the uh
i gotta be at the club and why
why were republicans allowing the heart
and soul of our country to be screwed
they were being screwed
what is the principle that requires
the impoverishment of the people who
make up
the american middle class the one who
built this country feed it fuel it
defend it
and i don't see it and i i got to give
donald trump credit for opening the eyes
of a lot of people
by saying what needed to be said he's up
there there's one guy he's one guy
there's 16 other guys
who are all talking about basically the
same stuff george bush was talking about
and donald trump's talking about the
real problems that people are talking
about our jobs going away
are our culture being hollowed out uh
wars that don't make any sense again i'm
not a pacifist
by any means but you know
as as i pointed out in my article today
you know the military's pretty angry at
tucker carlson
but uh tucker carlson has uh won as many
wars as they have in the last four years
he's also lost fewer that's right
uh and who pays that price
it's not the sons and daughters who go
to harvard west lake in west l.a
it's the paratrooper uh from uh omaha
hey well look you know we're really good
at building infrastructure in middle
eastern countries and really bad at
building it here
i i i'm driving around the karma what
the hell
you know the the the afghanistan papers
that that the washington post published
should have been a scandal on par with
the pentagon papers
about the disaster in vietnam and it
just kind of went
poof what were they uh it basically
talked about all our mistakes in
afghanistan after 20 years a war we have
not won after 20 years
the waste of money the waste of lives
the flawed strategy
it's it's been a disaster and
look i i was not i i wasn't against iraq
going in
and iraq went really well for about two
months
no follow-through strategy is not just
about
winning one battle strategy is about
achieving objectives
big objectives and
there was no strategy i mean i literally
got they literally
sent me to the army war college get me a
degree in strategy i must have made a
mistake because i listened
you know i mean i i took it seriously
and i'm looking at this i'm going okay
this via these things violate everything
i was taught about strategy
and i i just you know
avoiding the hard questions when when
you have
full kernels you know bro you know
colonels
tomorrow you're going to brief us on
america's greatest threat
you know what is our great strategic
threat and then the next day you will
brief us on your
your your strategy to address it basic
basic kind of war ecology thing and this
is a story somebody from a different war
college gave but it's
tracks with my own the first day 50
of the teams of colonels briefed climate
change
the weather in a hundred years was
america's greatest strategic
threat according to guys who typically
command 5 000 americans
wow i mean you're just like what the
hell
you know look an environment let's
assume it's even true
let's assume climate change isn't a
giant hoax and a scam
because it's one of those problems it
seems every solution happens to be
exactly every policy prescription
its advocates always wanted anyway but
that's that's an environmental factor
that is a factor in the situation
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time